very vividly recall this one guy saying
you have a case of alcoholism that we
only see in 65 year old lifelong
drinkers and if you don't get this right
you're going to go back out into the
world and you're going to die i was able
to hear that and as somebody who was
that guy who had so much promise you
know it was a pretty precipitous fall
and i never wanted to have to go back
and so i thought i'm going to stay here
and i'm going to make sure that i get
this right
[Music]
rich roll is in the house everybody
super pumped you're here man good to see
you good to see you nice haircut thank
you for coming to my home yes we've
switched sides i know we switched them
for people that are just listening i'm
sitting in lewis's chair and for people
on youtube it's going to be a little
jarring i think
i took over the scene exactly you know
to join you but it's good to see you i i
wanted to say that at the outset before
we even get into it that i really
appreciate you having me on i think this
is my third time third time podcast yep
and as we talked about on my show like
we go way back we started around the
same time
and i know how it is when past guests
kind of hit you up and say hey can i
come back on again and it can be awkward
so it's no small thing that you're
having me back on and i appreciate it i
appreciate you yeah you were on in 2013.
you were episode 10
yeah 2013 than 2015 episode 169 and now
600 something so 600 wow
i'm at 356 so you've almost doubled my
stock
wow yeah that's interesting it's been a
fun evolution for both of us you're a
little more than five years you're like
five and a half years i think right so
about five and a half yeah i'm five in
three months i think it is because it
was five at the end of january so
it's been a crazy journey right yeah i
look over here at the wall like some of
the people i've had on we got to get a
photo of you up there now we don't have
one up there and it's just like so many
lessons learned
and it sounds like it sounds like to me
there are a lot of lessons you've
learned since you wrote the first
uh edition of finding ultra until
now it's coming out with a hundred new
plus pages and a lot of lessons where
you're talking about before
you know after the book came out the
first time you almost lost your house
you were saying which i don't even know
that
and there was other challenges what were
the other challenges you've learned in
the last five years
since originally in this book coming out
so many uh you know setting aside
everything i've learned as a result of
doing the podcast as you know like
having these amazing people sit across
from you and you get to hold them
hostage and ask them everything you want
to ask them i mean i can't even begin to
unpack like how much that's impacted me
in a positive way i mean it's just been
an insane journey i don't think either
of us could have ever predicted that a
we'd probably we'd still be doing this
you know i didn't know that i would
still be doing this or that you know
what we've sort of built with our
respective you know audiences would have
grown to the extent that it has so super
grateful for that journey and
yeah you know i started the podcast
shortly after this book came out which
was in this book came out in may of
2012. i started the podcast in
um
november of that year and it was really
my intention you know i didn't even know
if i would do a second episode but once
i kind of got rolling it was an
opportunity to just continue the
conversation that i think this book
began
and one of the kind of you know core
themes of this book
you know a lot of people sort of mistook
it as a book about running or how to be
a better triathlete it's really not
about that it's about how to basically
better self-actualize how to become you
know the best most authentic version of
yourself however that looks for you and
my story is intended really as a
metaphor
for you know i think the unlimited
potential that that we all have but one
of the themes is
that when your heart is true that the
universe will conspire to support you
yeah and when this book came out i put
everything in into like pushing it out
into the world and let go of practicing
law my background is in corporate law
and i thought okay i'm going all in on
trying to
sort of
create some kind of profession out of
promoting these ideas that are important
to me
whether it's speaking or writing another
book or whatever that may look like i
wasn't really sure at the time but i
thought okay my heart is pure you know
this is the theme of the book i'm
putting myself out there i'm stepping
out and
i'm waiting for that universal signal of
support
and i gotta tell you like it didn't
really come you know i was like
phone's not ringing uh
what am i gonna do money was running out
and you know i could go do a speaking
gig for free or maybe do a little thing
here or there try to slap some books or
whatever yeah
you know and you know i have four kids
i've got a mortgage so we went through a
very difficult extended period of time
that lasted a number of years i mean
it's like five or six years
of touch and go julie calls it my wife
calls it our divine moment where we were
really brought to our knees
and forced to really confront um our
attachment to material things like our
house and our cars we had two cars
repossessed well after this book came
out i mean it's like it was the weirdest
juxtaposition because i was getting a
bunch of attention and i was sort of in
the you know in the media
and yet at the same time there was a lot
of kind of suffering that we had to
experience around
um you know how to how to kind of
navigate what we were trying to
accomplish and do in the material world
um and ultimately you know we really had
to burn in that fire in order to kind of
come out and i think that
um
you know it required a tremendous amount
of faith and persistence and really just
being in the moment like day to day to
try to figure out what the next step
would be
but i think
emerging from that i mean now
everything's great like my life is an
embarrassment of riches and i have so
much opportunity and it's insane like i
i you know i i it's it's hard looking
back to even imagine what it was like
back then but i think it
it allows me to communicate
um you know with the people that are
tuning into my channel and my frequency
with a level of humility and um
and honesty and and just realness really
because i know what it's like to kind of
be in that place yeah and that was one
of the reasons why
um i wanted to rewrite the book because
i wanted to tell that story of what
happened after finding ultra came out
from 2012 to present
because i think those events
are equally dramatic if not more
dramatic and and certainly more
relatable to the average person than
some of the ultra endurance feats you
know that are chronicled by the original
version yeah what would you say is the
biggest personal challenge for you over
the last five or six years
i think
um and this is a theme that you're
you know that you know well like it
really challenged my idea of what it
means to be a man like as a masculine
human being as a head of household not
perfect somebody who is supposed to be a
provider
somebody who's supposed to have all the
answers somebody who's supposed to make
their kids feel safe and all of that was
called into question because i was in a
position where for a period of time
providing for my family was a tremendous
challenge
and i would not have made it through
without the strength and support of my
wife i mean there were many times where
i was like
forget it i'm going back to being a
lawyer i'm gonna i'll get a job at a
corporate law firm whatever like we
gotta like you know we gotta like take
care of business here and she's like no
you cannot do that like you you've come
so far
you cannot retreat that's a that's a
move backwards like the only way
you would have out of this is through
yeah and i have your back and if we have
to say goodbye to our home like we're
together we're in love you know
we're with our kids it's all going to be
fine and
you know it's easier it's easy to kind
of say those things but to actually live
those things and and weather that storm
is a different matter altogether um and
so it was because of her in in large
part that you know i even get to sit
here and talk to you today it's a pretty
powerful woman yeah it's inspiring yeah
she's she's my biggest teacher for sure
really what's the big lesson she's
taught you
she just has
i mean she is somebody who is all who
has committed herself from the get-go to
always like
pushing the boundaries of our own
personal evolution like personal growth
so
whether it's spiritual mental emotional
like incredibly well-read person and
just somebody with an extreme amount of
personal fortitude like she's just an
incredibly strong person
and and very convicted in her ideas um
and so to have her as my partner who not
only
i mean she's the reason i even wrote
this book to begin with because you know
i was a junk food addict recovering
alcoholic like very unhappy in my
professional career but she was always
able to kind of
see through that facade that like
heaviness that i was carrying around to
this better more actualized person
within and she held the space for me to
to find that within myself and that's a
whole other story that's part of the
book as well um but i think just
you know that ability to kind of see the
best in somebody
and not in a lip service kind of way but
in a very real fundamental way um is is
rare yeah that's cool
do you see your story different now than
when you first wrote the book
uh yeah in so many ways
it's a weird thing and i'm sure you can
relate to this as well lewis
when
when you get asked to
get on a stage and tell your story or go
on podcasts and you know tell me what
happened and you know you know you you
get into this space where you tell the
story so many times
that
suddenly you think and i don't know if
you had this experience but i certainly
have you think like is the story even
true like
i've told it so many times that it's
easy to kind of like distance yourself
from it and just spit it out because
you've done it so many times and so
i've had that experience where i've
really had to think okay let me what is
the heart of the matter like what is
really true about this and what is just
something i've said so many times that i
think it's true so i'm constantly in the
process of like deconstructing that and
trying to examine it and i think
the the process of getting up on stage
and sharing my story with groups of
people large and small
has helped tell me what it is about
my story that connects with people and i
think when i wrote the original version
of the book i thought the story was one
thing and in the process of telling it
i've realized so much more about myself
right
and so it's changed and morphed not with
respect to the facts of that experience
but i think what
the emotional heart of it is yeah do you
think how old were you when you wrote
the book 45 46 i think i was 40 when i
was writing it i was 44 45 when it came
out in 46 so in 2012 that was seven
years ago i'm 51 now so
yeah whatever
45 yeah do you think your 45 year old
self would be proud of your 51 year old
self
oh for sure you know i i mean i've far
exceeded my expectations for
um you know not just the books that i've
written but the
the level of impact that i've been able
to have i mean my desire
really was only to figure out a way to
impact the most number of people in the
most meaningful way possible and i
didn't know like i said exactly what
that would look like or how i would
manifest that
but to sit here today you know as as a
fellow podcaster and author like i i
just
you know i can't even believe that um i
get to do what i what i what i get to do
every day like you know i i work really
hard as as i know you do it's like i'm
working all the time but it doesn't feel
like work i get is this we're working
right now right like it doesn't feel
like work i would come over and hang out
with you and do this you know anyway if
i had another job so
um very blessed to be able to uh
to to do what i love and and and also
provide for my family and and impact
people in a positive way i mean i i
can't think of anything that i would
rather do with my life but it's
certainly
not anything i would have dreamed that i
would be do like if you asked me when i
was 30
like
i mean i couldn't even imagine like i
thought i was going to be like
a baller lawyer or a movie producer or
something you know yeah so it's weird
what do you think
you would be most proud of
that you've done if it was your 45 year
old self again
meaning
from all the stuff you've been able to
do in the last seven years what's the
thing you're most proud of
um the thing i'm most proud of is
is that i know in my heart of hearts
that i have shaped and impacted the way
people lead their lives in a meaningful
way
whether that's one person 100 people a
thousand people however many people it
is just the feedback that i get um i
know and i know you get emails like this
as well you know to receive really
intimate um
heartfelt letters from people saying you
know i tuned into your podcast or i read
your book and this is where i was and
these are the obstacles i faced and here
here's where i am today and thank you i
mean
that's a gift from the universe you know
it's like
there's nothing there's nothing more
meaningful or valuable to me and uh like
i said you know it's
it's a blessing yeah you've been doing
the podcast for over five and a half
years do you think you'll be doing it
for another five years i don't know you
know i i the promise i made to myself
was i would do it until i started to get
stale or sick of it you know and i
actually ran up against that um around
december or january this year where i
was starting to feel a little bit burned
out for the very first time
and i had to hit pause and really
reflect on whether i wanted to keep
doing it and if so uh you know how to
configure reconfigure the way that i was
doing it so that i wouldn't have that
approach because i want to approach
every every interview every episode that
i do with enthusiasm and excitement so
um you've always been really good about
delegating you have this amazing team of
people helping you and and we've had
this conversation a lot of times where i
my achilles heel is that i'm a bit of a
control freak and i and i try to like
you know i get too in the weeds on the
details and so i've done a better job of
delegating and building my own team and
and also
you know focusing on the things that are
most important that only i can do and
letting other people handle the rest and
then batching the work like i wasn't
very systematic in my approach to it so
i ended up sort of working on it a
little bit every single day and i felt
like i was just drowning you know so
i've now created a schedule that allows
me some flexibility with my time and
that's improved my
perspective on the interview so to
answer your question yeah i'll do it as
long as i i feel like i'm adding value
and i'm into it you know the minute i
start to feel like
ugh
another one like then it's probably time
to either take a break or or you know
retire but it's something
we're not going to be doing this when
we're 70 right some at some point it's
going to be very good
yeah i guess he's doing he's on 60 000
yeah yeah but he takes breaks have you
ever taken a break
for me no not in five years yeah so i've
never missed a week
um i mean i took a break i went to
hawaii last week with no phone and no
computer yeah that's good and but i've
worked enough to be caught yeah then you
gotta work a lot before you go exactly
right to batch it ahead and now i gotta
get caught back up again so it's not
like
needing something for tomorrow oh we're
getting lean
it just always feels like that though
because we're doing two episodes a week
anyways
so you can get eight banks but then
they're gone the next month
um
you did this race last year right this
crazy endurance race was like 46 miles
that what it was through like the
galapagos islands or something i wish it
was the galapagos it was the water would
have been a little bit warmer it was
uh yeah yeah i hadn't i hadn't done
um an endurance challenge since epic
five in 2010 which is a really big part
of this book
and because in those intervening years i
was going through this dismantling
period and trying to figure out like how
to make my way and i was very intent on
on creating a sustainable
professional approach to what i was
doing and so i achieved that
um because before you're eating bad
having fast food well even prior to that
like when i was yeah i mean the story
leading up to it just to kind of catch
people up who have no idea who i am
i was a corporate lawyer at age 39 50
pounds overweight junk food addict you
know basically classic couch potato
sliding into middle age on a crash
course with lifestyle disease depressed
about my life and
had a uh and also like having an
existential crisis about like my career
my profession and what i was here to do
and that existential crisis sort of
collided with a health scare shortly
before i turned 40 where i had like a
heart episode walking up a simple flight
of stairs that really brought into focus
this desire to change how i was living
and in the in the sort of following
months and years i overhauled my diet
adopted a plant-based diet started
getting fit again went on and conquered
all these crazy ultra endurance
challenges wrote this book and like all
this crazy stuff happened is that story
even through anymore yeah i see
that's the thing like i just told you
the
thumbnail that i've said a million times
and you know we can dissect it if you
want but it's probably outside the
balance of this but
um
then it was about like okay i'm doing
the podcast i'm building i'm trying to
create you know something so you're
trying to build an audience that you can
also like you know on that on that theme
of like you know my approach has always
been like how can i have the most impact
and if i'm out on my bike for eight
hours or you know training all the time
then there's no podcast there's no you
know i'm not i'm not serving my my main
you know sort of
um mission statement
but i turned 50 last year and i thought
this is a good moment to race again
because i wanted to prove that a 50 year
old you know
dude who also happened to be vegan or
plant-based could still go out and kill
it and i thought that that would also
that would serve the mission statement
because there was a service aspect of
that so i committed to this race in
sweden called
the americans would call it otillo the
swedish pronounce it
which means island to island
and it's a race it's a 75 kilometer race
that traipses across 52 islands spread
wide across the stockholm archipelago in
the baltic sea
and leading up to this race i trained
for it for about i don't know nine or
ten months
i decided i was going to share every
single workout on strava and on
instagram stories so people could join
along and they could see like i have bad
days some days i
didn't make training because something
else happened and just be totally
transparent about the whole thing
which was super fun and then showed up
in stockholm and this race
it's the weirdest thing it's called swim
run this is called the this is the world
championships of something called swim
run which is an emerging sport
mostly in northern europe it's starting
to find its way to the u.s but nobody
knows about it here and essentially what
you do is you swim and you run and you
do the whole thing in a wetsuit with
your running shoes on uh it's gonna be
challenging swimming across these
waterways and
and crawling up on granite rocks on all
fours and scurrying across these little
islands and then jumping back in the
water and swimming again you do this 52
transitions
it was like a 10 hour race and you do it
in teams of two so i did it with my
coach chris health my long time coach
you have to stay within 10 meters of
your teammate the entire time you can't
get too separated and it was the hardest
one day race of my life i mean
just the distance alone was challenging
and the terrain was
way more difficult than i imagined
because on these islands you're not
really running it's more like an
obstacle course thing you're falling
down on rocks and
the conditions that day were insane
there was sideways rain
just crazy rain the swells and it was
like six feet swells in the water it was
bananas and freezing cold frigid water
in the baltic
uh there was one um that's scary you
could drown well in this race they would
they would have never allowed this race
to take place in the united states like
no insurance company would underwrite
this thing it's only like the vikings
who are like what's the big deal you
know
the the craziest part of that race was
about
two-thirds of the way through
there's a swim section it's one of the
longest swim sections it's called the
pig swim
it's about a kilometer across this
waterway it's the most exposed
area of water on the whole race where
there's no more islands there's this
baltic sea to your right and the swells
were so crazy the boats that were out in
the water who are sort of charged with
making sure everyone's safe
like these boats [ __ ] they're going to
capsize like it was crazy and i just
remember
halfway through
i kind of pulled up and looked around
like it's so disorienting because
um you're getting washed around like a
washing machine and suddenly you're
swimming the wrong way and you know it's
like you don't know where you are
i started laughing i was like what am i
even doing out here in the middle of the
50 year old dude like i'm in the middle
of the baltic i'm getting one it's like
what am i trying i can't even believe
what is going on in my life that i'm
here it was just
this moment of realization like that all
these things that i'd done and all the
challenges that i had overcome had put
me in this position to be in the midst
of this this totally
insane adventure race that was just
crazy and
it was great i didn't have the greatest
day to be honest with you yeah you
struggled yeah i definitely struggled
was your coach and partner was he
come on let's go no he was cool i was
like from the get-go i didn't sleep well
it was like it's a whole thing but like
you know he was mellow he's like okay
well just is what it is you know he
could have he could have been two hours
faster really
well he's a world-class machine yeah
but we were still the fastest american
team and you know we finished i don't
even remember where we finished like
30th place or something like that but
you know it wasn't about that it was
just about having this experience and it
was incredible it was incredible
to do it as a 50 year old man and to
show like i can still mix it up with you
know these world-class athletes and do
something that scared me because i hate
cold water everything i've done prior
was in hawaii and warm water
and uh and it was epic and the best part
of it was just that i got to share that
whole experience with the people you
know that follow me on the various
platforms and
and just demonstrate like look i showed
you exactly what i did every single day
leading up to this there's no magic
there's no mystery you know you saw the
whole thing
and my hope with that is that it it it
you know inspires other people to
rethink their own limits and their own
boundaries about what they're capable of
yeah it's powerful
you think you'll do it in 10 years at
60. i don't know we'll see that would be
sweet yeah
yeah yeah well every time i do one of
these things i'm like okay i'm good for
a while you know i'm not like racing all
the time but i i am looking for i'm on
that cusp of committing to something you
need a challenge every couple months
every couple of years you need a
challenge probably i think you always
need a challenge i think when i'm
committed to something like that um it
gives my life structure and focus and it
allows me to prioritize you know where
i'm where i'm spending my energy and
and my attention um and when i don't
have a goal like that it's easier to
just kind of
go with the flow and i'm not as
productive so even though there's a huge
time commitment with something like that
i tend to be more productive in
everything else that i'm doing when
i have a goal isn't it funny when we put
you know
bigger goals on our plate everything
else becomes productive because we have
structure we have time commitments and
we can get things done and it seems like
even if we have
more on our plate as long as we have big
goals that we're focused on
we just work around that and when we
have less on our plates or
no goals we kind of feel like we're lazy
or we're not as structured and organized
yeah there's no question about it i mean
when you have a goal and it's an
important goal to you then you're more
likely to create boundaries over what
you agree and don't agree to do right
and so although like i said like okay
that goal is going to require so much of
my time and energy
it draws focus on everything else that
you're doing so then you don't you're
like you're not on facebook in the
middle of the night you're not binge
watching netflix you're not just going
out to lunch and whatever like you're
like okay this is what i'm doing
and i'm just a happier more productive
person when i have that in my life you
know what i think you should do what
i think you should
i think you should create your own race
yeah i thought about that you should
create like the
but it's different than the obstacle
course races and just a marathon but
it's like your own spiritual journey
that people go on that is still
extremely
physically demanding
maybe there's a swim there's a bike
there's a run and there's some partner
stuff or whatever it is
but something that you get to be
creative with and create an experience
but also get to train for and practice
yourself
and then bring to life for your audience
yeah that's a good idea it could be like
an annual thing once a year the only
circumstances under which i would do
that lewis is if you agree to
participate
i will park well it depends
your audience would enjoy you preparing
for something
yeah i just gotta lose more weight
though
how many miles would it be i don't know
i haven't even thought about it there's
a lot the thing is like there's a lot of
people that are doing that
and they're not you no i'm not it's not
your experience you have your fans that
would come every year i did it once a
year yeah it didn't have to be like this
monthly thing and travel around the
world doing it but do once a year was
like an event an experience kind of like
what what's his name jesse did yeah
jesse edler yeah he's starting this new
thing where he's 100 mountain climbing
yeah he runs up the mountains and all
that did you do that or no no but um
something like that where he's coming
over to talk to me about it like i think
next week or something like that but i
you know i'm keyed into i had a friend
who did it he was like it was you know
painful and challenging but also really
cool experience i think it was a
killington the first one that he did and
that you just run you run up and down
the mountain until until you've uh
achieved the elevation of everest
everest was it yeah
right right right whatever yeah it's
cool um it's cool it's cool i i know i
think i think it's a good idea that'd be
fun to do yeah so i will
support it
and right okay check it out first
to see how the first year goes and then
all right well if you're watching on
youtube leave a comment below and let me
know what you think that that would look
like or you know hit me up i think it'd
be amazing because because i know you're
doing retreats now yeah which is
different those are more like
transformation right but imagine
creating a transformational race right
experience a journey i would potentially
i'd be open to doing it be very careful
about your work i would be open to doing
it there's nothing else that i've wanted
to do
like the la marathon my my buddy matt
he's like let's do it every year and i'm
like i just could care less yeah but it
was something that was different and
unique and like a journey right right
it's just the long endurance stuff is
like hard for me yeah like three months
but that's that's what that's what
attracted me to ultra endurance to begin
with because
as difficult as those challenges are
physically they're really spiritual
odysseys you know and at that point in
my life i was looking to connect with
myself i was looking to learn more about
who i was and what made me tick and when
you
train for these super crazy long races
you're just stripped down to your
core like until there's no like all the
it's almost like an ayahuasca trip like
all the
all the artifice like all that that
shell that you walk around with your
masks you know and become naked describe
yeah and you're confronted with yourself
in a really profound way and i learned
so much about myself as a result of
doing those but
on the other side of that it's like okay
i learned those lessons do it like do i
still need to like go and do it like yes
no i don't know you know what i mean
well i think
yes and no yes you can keep doing it
because there's always another evolution
of where you can grow into and i think
when you stop when you stop experiencing
pain
you know a certain type of pain i think
you become very complacent in your life
and you become lazier and that's why
what you do do is i think inspiring to
me because i try to do something every
single day that's painful like lately
i've been getting up at 5 30 a.m i don't
want to do it it's painful yeah i've
been lifting in the morning
it's painful i don't like it i'd rather
sleep in you know 10 hours a day i'd
rather do it but i feel so much more
productive when i
uh inflict some type of pain in my life
every single day of course something i
don't want to do uncomfortable and
that's why you know i think you inspire
so many people with
doing these endurance long endurance
races at the age you're at and
you know running circles around people
my age yeah well the thing that the
thing though that's so funny is that
like i'll share like on instagram
stories like oh here's the workout i did
today and people will be like that's so
inspiring you got me out of bed and i'm
like
i'm like actually i just prefer to do it
like i choose to do it like i enjoy it
you know what i mean and yeah it's
painful but that's
how you connect with yourself and that's
how i feel alive by pushing myself in
that way
i think you'd be more
impactful in the world
when you have something a challenge
every couple of years that you're
tackling it doesn't have to be a 50 mile
balkan sea race or whatever you know
that that crazy but something that
you're just doing i think you're going
to be more impactful in the world than
if you're just
hey guys here's what i did 10 years ago
yeah of course
of course yeah i totally i totally agree
with you you know and in many ways like
this book it's like these are most of
the stuff in here stuff i did a long
time ago yeah you know yeah
i think you should do it all right i'd
be interested all right i'm going to put
some i'll watch the first year and then
maybe do it the second year
like i said be very careful i know it
would be extreme wannabe man um
we talk a lot about
exercise meditation and diet both of us
the guests we have on
uh
if someone is looking to improve their
life and transform their life and they
wanted to get started with one aspect
diet nutrition
physical exercise and meditation which
one do you think should be obviously all
of them are equally important but if you
could only start with one for whatever
reason which one do you think is the
most important to start with
meditation nutrition physical activity
it's hard because they're so intertwined
with each other and it's hard to parse
one from the other so i'm reluctant or
reticent to say one versus the other but
if you're forcing me to do that i would
say
focus on your diet first you know i
think changing your plate
and cleaning up
the
the
the vibration of what you're putting
into your body is a portal to the soul
and if you are intentional about that
and
[Music]
you know really focus on
trying to
eat
real foods as close to their natural
state you know in my case i eat a 100
plant-based diet
if you're not ready to take that entire
leap just try to eat mostly
fruits vegetables nuts seeds legumes and
beans things like that
i think that that will be a catalyst for
future growth in those other areas and
that was my experience like i wasn't
ready to meditate or to you know return
to becoming an athlete or any of those
things i started with changing my
relationship with food
and i think when you change that
frequency of what you're putting into
your body it it impacts you on every
level not only emotionally spiritually
etc and it is a catalyst for progressive
growth from there so i would start with
that and the more you kind of refine
that
then suddenly you get interested because
you suddenly have a higher sense of
vitality you're like oh i feel like
going out and moving my body i haven't
felt like that way but so the fitness
will naturally follow and then you're
like wow my body feels good and i'm
taking care of it in this way like how
do i tend to my spirit and my emotions
in my mind well i guess i'll start
exploring the world of meditation
yeah i was watching this uh
thing on netflix called chef's table
have you ever heard this yeah yeah you
ever watch it or not i have yeah my wife
is obsessed with it i watched it for the
first time last night and just happened
to turn on a recent episode it was of
a woman who's a monk oh it's in south
korea is that where it is yeah so she's
uh she's in she is unbelievable genius
was amazing i forget her name
but she is basically a nun in this
buddhist monastery
and i believe it's in i believe it's in
i believe it's in south korea
um
and she's like a food magician she's
totally plant-based but she grows all
her herbs and her own foods and it is
the most artistic beautiful food that
you've ever seen and her approach to it
is so mindful and and so um
with so much grace
uh that it is impossible to not be
inspired and the food that she prepares
in this
monastery i guess and you would know
because you just watched the episode
it's called the temple food right which
is like the spiritual food for your soul
and your mind exactly i believe it's 100
plant-based i'm assuming it is yeah yeah
but they kept calling it she kept
calling it temple food
and how it's going to like infuse your
body with this like spiritual awareness
and enlightenment and they even had like
enlightened tea with like this
special flower you know thing and there
was a new york times
critic food critic who said he went to
this launch that she had and he was like
it was life-changing and then i had to
go to
korea or wherever it was to experience
it for 30 days and learn about it
that guy's name is jeff gordanier
that new york times writer and he did a
story on me and my family that was in
the new york times called vegans it was
called vegans go glam it came out a
couple years ago and when he came to our
house to interview us he had just come
from that experience he was like i gotta
tell you about he told us the whole
story and i was like okay like i didn't
really get it until that chef's table
episode came out and i was like oh now i
get it but but he wrote an incredible
piece for the new york times about her
and her work that i'm sure people can
find
that's interesting but food does
something to our physical
makeup and there's no question about it
yeah i mean you transform your physical
body and your energy transformed when
you transform the foods you've ate yeah
and like you know i don't want to sound
like a crazy woo hippie but
i believe that you sleep in a tent yeah
that's a whole other thing we can talk
about that if you want
when you take like high vibration live
foods into your body it's gonna it's
gonna have an impact that's different
from taking in something that is that is
dead yeah you know
and heavy
yeah i hear you
ever since my direct experience
an n of one experiment it's so funny
though there's other people you know
there's this guy mark bell have you seen
you know this is no he's got a podcast
and he's on instagram and youtube he's a
big bodybuilding guy he used to be like
really overweight i'm not overweight
just a big massive guy
he's leaner than ever he's still huge
and strong
he's on like the carnivore diet which is
all healthy meats but he looks healthier
and younger than ever
and leaner than ever and i'm just like
there's so many different diets out
there but i'm a big believer in a
plant-based diet
and ever since moving to l.a i've been
surrounded by you and my other friend
bill glazer who's just like been vegan
he's all about it he's been vegan for a
while and uh you know i just i go to
more
vegan restaurants and i just start to
eat more vegan foods but
it's just like a it's like a switch i
have to find the switch to be able to
turn it off
about meat and it wasn't until i watched
okaja did you watch this yeah yeah once
i watched ocho where i actually had an
emotional connection to
to meet but it only lasted for about a
month
and then i don't know i can justify it
some other way there's other doctors who
talk about you know how meat is good for
you when you have a certain types
whatever so
it's challenging but you gave me some
good advice you said you know if you're
going to eat meat at least don't eat
dairy
yeah that's what you told me i think
it's like dairy is one of the worst
things in your mind yeah cut out dairy
um cut out dairy and just and limit your
meat intake if you're not ready to go
100 plant-based so right now even if
you're the most informed and diligent
consumer and you're poking around the
internet it can be very very confusing
there's so much debate and acrimony when
it comes to this conversation that we're
having about what is the optimal human
diet
but i think all
or most of the
[Music]
experts and certainly the ones that i
respect the most
will agree upon one fundamental fact
which is
that a diet high in fiber fruits
vegetables nuts seeds legumes beans
these things
is really the path forward and when you
kind of look at the blue zones and the
people that live the longest and the
happiest these are people who are eating
a very small
amount of meat at most maybe some fish
and their diet is basically consists of
of you know what i just mentioned and so
i think there's wisdom in that and we
want to over complicate it we want to
say it we want to be reductionist about
it it's this not that
so for anybody who's listening who's
struggling because they are confused by
all of that like if you're not ready to
cut meat out you know just make it a
side dish and make the main entree 80
tons of vegetables
that's it yeah
um so you're recovering you're you are a
recovering addict right how long were
you uh
alcoholic for
uh so i was now i was an alcoholic i was
probably my first drink around
17
and i got sober 31
i am a recovering alcoholic
alcoholism took me to some some pretty
dark entire places
uh you know at age 30 31 um
you know i was somebody who
who had really squandered
um a lot of potential and opportunity
you know when i was a senior in high
school i got into every college i
applied to i was
olympic hopeful yeah
i don't know that i was good enough to
be an olympic hopeful maybe i was with
an emphasis on hope
and practice
yeah no i was i was i was worldwide
swimmer i swam at stanford in the late
1980s we won two nc2a championships when
i was there yeah i was a benchwarmer
though let's be clear about that
um and alcoholism really you know
destroyed destroyed my potential as an
athlete it undermined every aspect of
who i was it stripped me of all my
ambitions and potential and by the time
i was 31 i was a pretty broken human
being you know i was alienated from my
friends and my family i was you know the
guy who just never showed up and would
lie to you and
you know sleeping on a bare mattress in
a shitty apartment with no furniture in
it about to get fired from my job i had
two duis and i just could not stop
drinking i could not stop drinking of
course i knew i was an alcoholic and i
just had that moment of clarity you know
one day that you hear about with people
that are in recovery where i was like i
i just can't i can't live this way
anymore
i ended up going to a treatment center
in oregon
um where i thought i was going to go for
you know the 28-day deal that most
people do
and i ended up living there for 100 days
which is kind of a long time um did you
feel like you needed to stay and because
you weren't ready to leave and go back
to the real world of what happened was i
got there and
and i started telling people how i was
actually living and what i was doing for
the very first time and the counselors
there were like dude like i know you
think you're gonna spin out of here in a
couple weeks but we really think that
you need to stay like you have
very vividly recall this one guy saying
uh you have a case of alcoholism that we
only see in 65 year old lifelong
drinkers and if you don't get this right
you're going to go back out into the
world and you're going to die and i see
it all the time and
i was able to hear that
and
i was very aware that my best thinking
had me essentially in a mental
institution
uh and as somebody who was that guy who
had so much promise you know it was a
pretty precipitous fall and i i never
wanted to have to go back and so i
thought i'm gonna stay here and i'm
gonna make sure that i get this right
yeah
and that's what i did you know and then
in the wake of that
you know came back to los angeles
and my priority was to build the
strongest foundation of sobriety that i
could and that was my number one thing
going to a meetings and immersing myself
in the community here the recovery
community in los angeles and then
trying to repair all the wreckage that i
had created as relationships yeah
relationships and just professionally
and
and really i was like i used to be here
i fell this far i got to get back up on
top and in retrospect looking back i
wasn't really aware of it at the time i
took a lot of that compulsive addict
energy and i put it into my work you
know i was like i and i and i justified
it by saying
look you know i have this potential i
got to regain it you know i have to
repair this and
and it worked you know by the time i was
39 i had succeeded i had repaired those
relationships you know i was succeeded
in business successful lawyer like
partnership track a law firm
had a portion to drive i had all the
stuff you know but that's when that
existential crisis started to percolate
up because i i never really thought like
is this what i want to do i just it was
more like i need society to perceive me
in this way and this is what somebody of
my education is supposed to do without
ever really taking a beat to say well
what is it that that i want to do like
what's unique to me what gets me excited
and out of bed in the morning that was
never part
of the inner mental dialogue and nothing
that i ever really considered in a real
way
and that just played it out played
itself out as long as it could until
you know i had that second bottom you
know on that staircase which was very
similar to that bottom that i had with
drinking you know where i realized like
my life is unsustainable like i need to
make some significant changes when did
you get married
i got married about
17 years ago
no actually well julie and i have been
together about 20 years but we didn't
get married for a long time so we got
married my daughter's
14. we got married about 15 years ago
you met her after you went to rehab i
remember when i had a year of sobriety
god yeah and i was i was celibate during
that year because when i left rehab they
were like look your relationship with
women is very intertwined with your
drinking and we think emotionally pause
on that and take this time to really
figure out who you are and and that was
another thing i took seriously and that
was a very empowering thing to be
celibate for a year wow and and really
kind of opt out of dating altogether
because you're really then forced to
like deal with yourself and then at the
end of that year i met julie and then
like that was it wow yeah do you think
you guys would be together if you would
have met two years prior no way
i would have been a wreck and she was
married no it wouldn't happen yeah it
wouldn't happen and like
you know on paper like julie was not the
person for me and i wasn't the person
for her uh it didn't really make she was
older she was she was coming out of a
marriage she had two young boys like i
was thinking my next girlfriend's gonna
be
you know five years younger than me and
like really just no drama you know no
complications or anything like that
but you know the heart wants what the
heart wants right how has that evolved
in the last 20 years since you've known
her and it's been incredible you know i
mean prior to meeting her i couldn't
sustain a relationship i couldn't be
honest i couldn't be faithful
and i was really scared to be in a
relationship with her especially since
she had two boys
um and you know we're going on almost 20
years now it's been incredible and it's
been
you know it's been an evolution you know
of of trying to figure out how to
cohabitate with another human being for
that long period of time is challenging
and i think one of the things that's
allowed us to
um
to continue to grow alongside of each
other is that she is very independent
and i'm independent and you know i'm not
looking at each other it's like it's
like you complete me it's like it's not
that like we're on our own journeys you
know our our our personal growth
trajectories are between ourselves and
and our version of god really yeah and i
don't rely on her to fix me and she's
not looking to me for the same
and so we can come together and like
make magic and you know we work together
too we write cookbooks together we do
retreats so we're professionally
enmeshed as well as we are personally
enmeshed and you know as parents of four
kids
i think
it's easy to
allow a relationship to then be defined
by um
what you guys are doing together
in a career
context you know like all your
conversations are about like okay we
gotta did you email that person back and
what are we doing about this and so
we've had to be very diligent about
making sure that we know when we're
working together and when it's like
personal family first time yeah that's
cool and what has uh
being a recovering addict taught you
about compassion for others
oh it's been huge
it's been huge um
you know all the
all the tools that i've learned to
navigate the world began with what i
learned in rehab and what i continue to
learn in recovery
um and it's it's made me much more
compassionate towards other people
because
i've come to understand that
that you know we all have our own pain
you know when you're in the recovery
community
you're constantly
meeting people and hearing their stories
you know what it was like for them what
happened and what it's like now
and and you become very connected with
that
journey of
how life can be very difficult and
and i think whether you're an addict or
not
um
we're all walking around in the world
with our masks on and it's easy to just
presume or project onto other people
that they have it easy or that they're
not you know
having the same struggles that you are
having but in truth i've come to
understand and learn and really take to
heart that
that you know you don't know what people
are going through and i've gone through
a lot and i've been in a very dark low
place and so
um
i don't really judge other people's
experiences you know and that's a
perspective i brought into the podcast
too even when i have people on that i
don't agree with or don't see the world
in the same way
i'm able to have empathy for them and
i'm able to kind of find a way to uh you
know respect whatever not judge or make
wrong yeah
what's the big lesson that you try to
teach your kids now
i think the big lesson well it's it's
multi-fold but but i think at the core
of it is
is teaching them that the most important
thing
well as parents the most important thing
i want to instill in them is a
sense of self-assuredness and
self-confidence
belief in themselves yeah belief in
themselves
and then with that um i try to encourage
them to find something that they care
about and i don't really care what that
is you know i just want them to have
something that excites them and then my
job and my wife's job is to find a way
to fuel that and support that because i
think that's the engine
that will propel an individual to
success later in life rather than saying
you should have this career you should
have that career like whatever it is
that they're naturally gravitating
towards like i try to pay attention to
that and then find a way to
be a support system for that so for
example my my 14 year old daughter
started painting when she was like four
years old five years old she sold
paintings to you know our friends when
she was a little girl
she moved away from it for a while and
then she came back to it and then she
decided on her own
that she wanted to apply to get into the
um performing arts school here in los
angeles was very difficult to get into
so we got her a mentor this young girl
who had gone to art school
and she worked with her for over a year
helping her learn how to paint putting a
portfolio together she applied to the
school and she just got in so that's
super exciting and
and you know so the the analogy is it
took me a very long time to find
something that i cared about that i
could invest myself in and my message
that i put out in the books and what i
write about and the podcast and all of
that is like you know find what what is
true to your heart and pursue that with
everything that you have so i have to
believe that that is true for myself and
the people that i'm communicating with
that it has to be true with my children
as well yeah
what's the biggest challenge of being a
parent
the biggest challenge is is
um understanding that you
um you can't control their environment
you know that you have to allow them to
have their own experiences and come to
their own conclusions even if you know
what's best
your job is to kind of guide them gently
in a direction that you see fit
but when they stumble or they end up
making a bad decision
you have to sometimes step back and
allow that to unfold without getting
overly involved in it that's kind of
which is so challenging for a control
freak yeah who wants them to be like do
this no no yeah but like
you know i've learned from the way that
i grew up that you know it's important
to to provide a little bit of space and
freedom and and and and you can't you
can't insulate them
from the pain that life is inevitably
going to deliver
um so your job isn't to
make sure that they avoid that at all
costs but to make sure that they're
loved and supported when something like
that inevitably occurs yeah and are your
parents still around mm-hmm yeah what's
in washington d.c they do yeah they're
still together
well yeah yeah what's the biggest
lessons you learned from both of them
that's a good question um my father is
um a gentleman's gentleman he's a he's a
he's a very successful lawyer in
washington dc and now he's become an
author himself so we're both writing
books and we can bond over that that's
cool um i think what i learned from him
is is
and from my mom as well who's an
educator
is the um
the importance of of learning and
education like that was something that
was impressed upon me at a young age
probably not in the healthiest way maybe
a little tick too much
um but
uh but a respect for
um the importance of learning not just
in school but throughout throughout your
life
that's cool
and what's the biggest challenge you're
faced with right now hmm
i think the biggest challenge
that i'm faced with right now is
learning
what to say no to mm-hmm
because my life is big
opportunity
as you know i'm sure you're in this
situation all the time you're on the
receiving end of a lot of cool
opportunities and it's because life was
so hard not so long ago like now i'm in
a position to take advantage of things
that were not being offered to me then
and it's all awesome like i want to say
yes to everything because it's all super
cool so the challenge is being clear on
what it is that i'm actually doing and
making sure that the decisions i'm
making are driving that forward rather
than using those opportunities as
distractions that ultimately prevent me
from being as impactful or successful as
i know that i can be it's instead of
being good at lots of things being great
at a few things and staying focused
right well for example like somebody
says hey we want to pay you a bunch of
money to come and speak at this
conference and it's some at some really
cool resort and we'll put you up and all
of that and it's like yeah i want to do
that then you're like but if i do that
then that's all this time away and i'm
gonna fall behind in this other project
that i'm working on so in the balance of
things like what is most important for
me to do yeah you know when i hear you
so saying no having boundaries um that's
that's difficult for me and you know i'm
a i'm a people pleaser at heart you know
yeah uh so it's difficult for me to say
no to anything i hear you i'll make sure
not to ask you
no you can't just kidding
um before i ask the final few questions
i want to make sure you guys get the new
book or the updated book finding ultra
rejecting middle age becoming one of the
world's fittest men and discovering
myself very powerful updated expanded
100 plus new pages nutritional stuff in
there as well make sure you guys check
this out very powerful story journey
insights
all the things uh you got a new cookbook
out too yeah that's right so
this second edition of finding ultra
just came out super excited about it and
i appreciate the fact that you had it
was there this was sitting up there yeah
i could see it in all your videos and i
would just pull this out
i was waiting for you i was like how
long is that going to sit up there
before he swaps it out but i i it's not
lost on me that you had that there and i
appreciate it we get rid of lots of
books
keep the favorites yeah thank you um
i wanted to take the opportunity to
rewrite it for the reasons i already
mentioned to bring it up to speed but
it's about 100 pages longer
it's got a brand new prescriptive
chapter that has all the tools and the
resources and the strategies that i
employ to transform my life it's got a
new forward it's got beefed up
appendices it's got a recipe section
there's all kinds of bells and whistles
so even if you
read it originally and enjoyed it
there's plenty there for you to
enjoy the second time around and then
yes on april 24th we have a new cookbook
coming out called the plant power way
italia
we had my wife and i wrote a book
several years ago away this is yeah
italian italy lewis ohio boy
um this book is like next level 125
plant-based recipes italian
everything's italian it's informed by
these retreats that we do every year in
the tuscan countryside working with
chefs there and taking groups of people
through a week-long transformation and
we took all of that put it in this
amazing book and super excited that's
pretty cool yeah it's it's good like the
photography everything is like it's like
a coffee table book you're going to want
to leave out you're going to want to use
it all the recipes are very family
oriented family friendly
delicious they're going to fill you up
it's not just salads like it's all the
good stuff that's amazing love about
italian food wow sounds amazing and i
heard a rumor that if you pre-order a
copy of that you're entered into a
contest to potentially get a free ticket
to the next retreat is that what i heard
yeah that's a wow you did your homework
so yeah we just announced this contest
um well we do
we're going back to italy in may 19-26
and we're taking a group of about 35
people it's sold out but somebody a
woman had to back out for some reason so
we had this extra with this open spot
and we were thinking well we'll just
we'll sell it and then we thought well
let's use this opportunity this
pre-order campaign to like
offer this spot to somebody who wants it
so
yes that's it's only for it's a woman
only because it's in a shared female
room
so it's only available to women but if
you're interested in in uh learning more
about that go to my
website and i have a blog post up that
has a form to fill out and all that good
stuff yeah so you got to buy the book
and then enter the form i'm assuming
yeah so that's richrol.com
for that
um
very cool uh final couple questions this
one is called the three truths i think i
asked the two last time but i'll ask it
again
if this was your final day for you many
years from now and you've achieved
everything you want it became your
greatest self
tackled everything every challenge
any dream you had you made come true
wrote all the books everything but for
whatever reason you had to take
everything with you on your last day so
nothing could stay for us to have access
to these books or the content you put
out there it's all
with you in the grave and gone into
another spiritual realm
uh but you did have the opportunity to
leave behind one piece of paper
with the three things you need to be
true about all your lessons in life all
your experiences that you would share
with the world and this is the only
thing that we would have to have access
to your words and wisdom
what would you say are your three truths
wow man that's tough let's see
you did not ask me this before so this
is new
um
i would say
live true to yourself
give freely to others
and love deeply
not much more than that is important
there you go
powerful
um i want to acknowledge you for a
moment rich for constantly showing up i
mean you're 51 you put me to shame with
your health
your abilities everything but
your compassion towards humanity and
wanting to just
love on people in the sense of not
judging people making people wrong i
think that's one of your biggest
superpowers is your ability to
lead through humility
while putting yourself through any type
of challenge or adversity and just share
your story and i think the art of
storytelling has been lost for a lot of
us we don't think we are
who are we to share our story publicly
and your ability to do it and continue
to show up and share it even though it's
not
perfect every day for you is really
inspiring and powerful so i acknowledge
you for that man thank you my friend of
course it's a privilege and an honor to
sit across from you once again
and uh mad love and respect for
everything that you're doing and what
you've built here and the service that
you provide to so many people so it's
always always good to see you and
appreciate it i appreciate it final
question what's your definition of
greatness
my definition of greatness is is really
probably
a variation on on what i would leave
behind you know it's like to to be great
is to live uh in a way that is that has
fidelity to who you truly are like are
you fully self-actualized so to be great
is to
is to live in that sec self-actualized
way and and
to give away freely
the wisdom that you've accumulated as a
result of of uh
of trudging that road
rich roll
the legend my friend appreciate it man
appreciate it
you